hallo
okay hallo ihr lieben einen fröhlichen
dritten Advent und Willkommen zu vlogmes
Nummer 3 warum ich krank bin das erfahrt
ihr in diesem Vlog
[Musik]
am Montag früh ging es endlich nach
London
es ist ich weiß es nicht mal
halb drei halb drei in der Nacht und ich
habe eine halbe Stunde geschlafen denn
als ich aus York wieder zurückgekommen
bin mussten wir noch fünf asmr-videos
Drehen der Block müssen musste online
gehen ein anderes asmr-video musste
online gehen und jetzt ist es mitten in
der Nacht und ich parke um gleich in
einer Stunde nach London zu fliegen ich
freue mich da so tierisch drauf aber ich
habe nicht realisiert dass wir einen
Flug um
6:20 Uhr gebucht haben
der kann jetzt noch schlafen
oh nein
oh ja ja ja
nachdem ich alles fertig gepackt habe
bin ich so schnelles geht zum Bahnhof
denn ich fahre immer mit der Bahn zum
Flughafen BER und ich fahre immer vom
gleichen Gleis nur an dem Tag aus
welchem Grund auch immer ist dieser Zug
von einem anderen Gleis gefahren es
könnte sein dass es daran liegt dass es
ein Regio war und nicht dieser Text Flex
train also hatte ich eh schon zwei
Minuten zum Umsteigen und bin dann zum
falschen Gleis also hatte ich eine halbe
Minute um zum richtigen Gleis zu kommen
und das war sehr schwer ich habe es dann
aber geschafft und dann war ich auch
schon am Flughafen und habe Vincent und
nach Omi getroffen wie ein Profi
das ist gerade so anstrengend durch das
alles zu erzählen aber ich will das
unbedingt machen also willst du mich
freuen wenn ihr weiter schaut auch wenn
ich heute nicht so enthusiastisch bin
wie sonst es wird einfach nur euer
Reiseblog einfach ganz ehrlich ich mache
hier Naomi und Vincent Reise fahren also
ihr könnt euch das ein paar Jahren
angucken und dann wenn man eine Kamera
mitschaut danke danke
London angekommen wow ist das ein
Charakter von deinem Spiel
von Fortnite
und danach sind wir was frühstücken
gegangen und ich habe ganz zufällig so
ein super süßen Laden gefunden da war
ein total schön geschmückter Baum die
Leute waren darin super nett und ja das
war die erste richtig positive
Erfahrungen in London ja verratet man wo
seid ihr jetzt geht es gut
gefunden
zeigen möchte
stimmt ab Leute in die Kommentare wie
sollen meine Ex sein postedt oder Boyle
Benedikt Benedikt ja Englisch ja
ich fand die Reise jetzt ein bisschen
anstrengend die war zwei Stunden lang
[Gelächter]
nein der hat gesagt es singen wir schon
auf Espresso with bei so funktioniert
doch aber das meinte er dann noch mal am
Ende da habe ich das auch anders
verstanden anyways das ist Naomis Latte
materiato zeig mal zeig mal wie groß ist
wir sind ja gar nicht so groß
[Musik]
ich hatte so Zucchini maispuffer mit
Hummus wirklich sehr lecker und was ich
unbedingt mal ausprobieren wollte das
ist nämlich so ein tiktok Trend diese
Mais
[Musik]
lecker auch zehn zehn
und nach dem Essen ist auch genug Zeit
vergangen und wir konnten zu unserem
Airbnb als wir beim Airbnb angekommen
sind hatte ich auf jeden Fall ein paar
Höhen und Tiefen okay
der Ausblick ist wirklich amazing
wir können den echten ins Bett
reinkommen
warum sieht das jetzt so riesig aus what
the [ __ ] the du da guck mal jetzt mal
schön Neustadt
Hammer na zum Glück haben wir die andere
Wohnung nicht bekommen
wäre echt cool
ja doch komm wir machen so schön hier
wir machen uns das kuschelig aber der
Geruch da drin ist echt unangenehm
London und Flats unsere letzte war
irgendwie genauso
hoch das nimmt ganz bestimmt nicht ihr
euch das weil sonst ist ziemlich früh
aufstehen
du auch nein die nächsten drei Tage
so groß wie ich ja deine die zwei
kleinen Zwerge kriegen da das Dings und
wir ja also willst du mich freue mich
schon auf die Nacht
von unserem Flatscreen oh mein Gott ist
gerade warum muss mein Kopf geht
wirklich
gerade
hindrehen aber
so die bei Seven vs Wald haben es ein
bisschen schwerer als wir aber ich
glaube ich werde das Überleben aber
sehen wir dann die nächsten Tage ne also
ich meine das ist ja schön alle die uns
jetzt sehen werden sagen ja
und für den Preis sind mir gezeigt haben
ist schon ein bisschen
das wollen wir nicht wissen okay ich
mache jetzt ein bisschen Mittagsruhe ich
habe keinen keine Sekunde geschlafen
doch ich habe zwei Stunden im Flugzeug
geschlafen haha
was habt ihr oh wie lieb danke schön
Mittagsschlaf gemacht
vitalisiert
ready for the day warum habe ich denn so
Augenringe
und dann machen wir wieder weg und dann
wir beide so total mega also
coole Party Outfit transition in 3 2 1
[Musik]
Kind
tiktok machen wenn Sie diesen tiktok
Star oh Gott müssen wir zum Musik laufen
oder was
zeig meine Make-up Skills am Montag war
der fünfte dezember und Naomi hatte
Nikolaus also dem 6 Dezember Geburtstag
das heißt wir sind losgezogen um in
ihren Geburtstag rein zu feiern
wir waren auf einem Konzert von der DJ
von kehlani und wenn ich euch sage dass
ich in meinem Leben bei einem Konzert
noch nie so viele Handys gesehen habe
ich meine ihr seht selbst in sale
[Applaus]
[Musik]
lag aber auch daran dass kehlani
höchstpersönlich da war und das
natürlich für alle so eine tolle
Überraschung war und Naomi hat sich mega
gefreut und es waren mega schöne Abend
bis wir meine Füße weh getan haben und
erstmal meine Schuhe um 4 Uhr nachts vor
dem Club wechseln musste
Vanessa ziehen einfach diese Schuhe an
zu feiern Leute ich dachte wir bleiben
nicht so lange wir so viel Stunden
getanzt naja
oh mein Gott
wow ich bin jetzt 26 das war nämlich
auch der Zeitpunkt als Camilla Naomis
und Vinzenz Freundin gekommen ist und
dann war auch schon der nächste Tag
Naomis Geburtstag und Nikolaus
am neuen Charakter hier entwickelt
Camilla
hallo wir waren gestern noch bis 5 Uhr
unterwegs und haben aber gar nicht so
viel Alkohol getrunken deswegen sind wir
alle jetzt topfits
nachdem wir uns dann fertig gemacht
haben sind wir dann frühstücken gegangen
okay danke schön
worauf freust du dich heute auf den Tag
am meisten geschneit
[Musik]
gerade gut erkennen konnte man muss ja
einfach seine Bankkarte auf diese Türen
öffnen legen oh Mann
das ist das ist voll cool die
ärger mich weil hier meine Community was
erzählen möchte also mein legt seine
Bankkarte auf den Türöffner für die
Schranken wenn man reinsteigt und wenn
man raussteigt und dann wird es halt
abgerechnet kann sein natürlich auch
sein Handy drauflegen wenn du Apple hast
oder wenn du eine Bahnkarte hast dann
liest seine Bahnkarte drauf aber ich
fand das am Anfang so komisch dass ich
einfach meine EC-Karte drauflegen und
die Türen sich öffnen und dann ja das
ist irgendwie dann so ist ohne nichts
anderes
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Videos plötzlich machen das ist mein
thing als Video Graf das ist
voll scheiße bei mir gemacht weil du
nicht bearbeiten kannst nein
fluffy Pancakes waren richtig lecker und
Naomi hat mir das einzige übrig gelassen
was ich die essen darf
Pancakes gegessen auch wenn sie mega gut
aussahen ich esse keine Laktose und
Vincent mag nichts Süßes zum Frühstück
also haben wir gewartet bis wir zu einem
food Markt gekommen sind den Vincent
auch schon kannte
wir haben doch gerade schon darüber
gesprochen wie krass einfach London
aussieht ne ja ich liebe London so und
wir haben beide gesagt dass wir hier
gerne leben wollen würden vielleicht
heiraten wir einfach beide einen
Engländer ja let's go und so Brüder
unsere zusammen in einer Villa und du
zahlst alles also reiche Brüder sind das
aber
er hat mir die ganze Zeit von panypuri
erzählt
was ist das das ist lecker das zeige ich
euch gleich
ja natürlich
und eigentlich ist indisch überhaupt
nicht so meine Geschmacksrichtung aber
ich dachte wenn er so darüber schwärmen
muss ich sehr probieren jetzt habe ich
mir doch genommen
ja auf Vincent und Empfehlung nächstes
Leute wer hat noch da liegen
[Musik]
okay
das wieder komplett in die Fresse ab
[Musik]
also den letzten zeige ich jetzt auch
noch mal jetzt bin ich ja auch panypuri
Experte hier an dieser Stelle
suppenbombe
[Musik]
das erste was ich gemacht habe als ich
wieder zurück in Berlin war ist panypuri
in Berlin zu googeln und ich glaube es
gibt sogar ein paar places die wir auf
jeden Fall besuchen müssen weil ich muss
das Timo zeigen hier habe ich das
Sandwich für 30 € gegessen aber es hat
mir leider gar nicht geschmeckt aber ich
muss es dann reinzwängen weil ich so
viel bezahlt habe dafür und danach haben
wir einfach das gemacht
Sachen anschauen rum spazieren und
einfach die Stadt genießen oh da ist die
Themse
[Musik]
da ich die ganze Zeit am Film bin muss
ich mich auch selber Filmen ne schön
wir sind gerade auf der Suche nach dem
Besonderen Apple Cider den Anna Omi und
Vincent das letzte Mal hier hatten und
wir haben noch nichts gefunden
[Musik]
Erinnerung
kommen
[Musik]
ich habe sehr große Hunger
ich trage die ich trage im chinesischen
die glücksfarbene gut
[Musik]
aber lecker
hat sich Pinguin mit reingenommen und
jetzt sag mal was zu dem Pinguin ja nimm
mich an mein erstes Mal in England und
da sind immer Witze drauf
[Musik]
cool guck mal das ist so ein mega cooles
ding davon habe ich schon überall gehört
heute zum ersten Mal aber okay
das ist eine Schoko Orange und die hält
sich wohl
oh mein Gott oh mein Gott
wow aber ist schon guck mal links das
ist ein richtiger orange süß und viele
Scheibchen also das Prinzip ist schon
mal cool
lucky
es schmeckt wie Erfrischungsstäbchen als
ob du Erfrischungsstäbchen in einen
Mixer reingemacht hast und dass das du
musst das ausprobieren
[Musik]
aber es ist auch mit Real orange und es
ist ja immer noch Naomis Geburtstag
deswegen sind wir boah wir sind danach
zu shake shake gegangen aber das habe
ich nicht mal gefilmt weil die Burger so
schlecht waren ich weiß nicht ob es an
dem shake shake lag oder ob shake shake
einfach schlechter geworden ist aber die
waren nicht gut aber um die Laune wieder
hochzukriegen wollen wir danach beim
Karaoke
und egal in welcher Stadt ich bin ob es
New York ist Soul oder London
Karaoke singen macht einfach Spaß
weil du hast dieses Party Feeling du
kannst mit deinen Freunden irgendwie
auch mal zusammen sein und ja es macht
einfach mega viel Spaß
hallo
also der Karaoke-Abend war gestern sehr
lustig wir haben gestern einfach 20.000
Schritte oder noch mehr gemacht das ist
halt wenn man irgendwo unterwegs ist ne
und alles zu Fuß macht und mit der Bahn
dann ist das echt krass wie viel man
sich bewegt ich bin ehrlich mit euch ich
könnte die ganze Zeit einfach nur
schlafen was ist der Plan für heute
heute gehen wir ein bisschen
tourismus-sachen machen wir gucken uns
den Big Ben an und Buckingham Palace und
den Park dazu und alles so ich habe noch
eine Maske aus Korea gehabt die habe ich
mir heute draufgepasst wunderbar die
wird mein Gesicht aber auch nicht retten
ich brauche Schlaf aber die lassen mich
schlafen zum Schluss gibt's noch eine
coole transition von so äh wie sehe ich
aus zu richtig cool sexy und hübsch
schön zwischen wow jetzt ist es wie
immer wir warten auf Vincent weil der
ähm längsten
Outfit Check okay oh sind wir heute die
Öhrchen gefallen
[Musik]
hallo
ja es wird heute ein schöner Tag aber
solche timo hat mir schon verboten zu
viel zu viel jetzt habe ich Angst bei
jeder Szene das ist schon zu viel ist
Challenge Timo
steht in der Schlange
Technologie ich will dass du den
probierst okay na gut dann lass uns
einen holen
[Musik]
wäre
vorstelle
[Musik]
Buckingham Palace
Vincent
and Palace
[Gelächter]
Naomi wird mal wieder erkannt die
international Fans hier du hast mich
auch ganz toll jetzt ist mein Ego
gepusht okay ich liebe den Park am
Buckingham Palace einfach nur wegen den
ganzen süßen Tierchen wieder rumlaufen
also hier hätte ich jetzt schon mal
einen Punkt bekommen bei Seven vs wild
ich weiß nicht ob es den gut geht die
sind also die Eichhörnchen
ich bin so nah an ein Eichhörnchen
angekommen das hat einfach meinen ganzen
Tag gerettet man könnte dieser Erfahrung
schon als kleine Safari bezeichnen die
ganze Zeit nicht so also noch mal zu
komisch ne komische Vögel gehört nicht
in Köln fliegen ja genau wir haben
gerade schon darüber
gesprochene Licht hier Timo wenn du hier
wärst könnten wir ein paar Fotos machen
[Musik]
Bio schlimmeres
der absolut größte fails passiert und
zwar darf ich meine blockkamera nicht
hier haben dabei sieht das so schön aus
und ich habe sie endlich ja guck mal wo
sie jetzt ist reicht
die ist einfach hier und die ist so
schwer ah ja jetzt gibt es vielleicht
ein paar Handyaufnahmen wenn meine
Motivation das noch zulässig ich habe
mich so darauf gefreut ich habe sie zum
Glück habe zum Glück habe ich oh wie ein
Bratwurst zum Glück habe ich meine
Tierdoku noch gefilmt weil sonst wäre
ich jetzt echt deprimiert gewesen
mitgenommen Mann
[Musik]
und weil ich meine Kamera nicht beim
winter wonderland auspacken durfte habe
ich euch noch mal schöne London
christmas lights eingefangen denn für
mich war der Hauptgrund im Dezember nach
London zu fliegen die weihnachtliche
Stimmung jede Ecke ist dort so
weihnachtlich geschmückt sie übertreiben
maßlos mit ihren christmas lights und ja
es ist einfach wunderschön
hier beenden wir unsere London Reise ja
jetzt passiert nichts mehr wir haben
gerade gegessen naja ich sag dann schon
mal tschüss von Service
und wir picken jetzt in Willi
am Donnerstag ging unser Flug ziemlich
spät zurück zum 19 Uhr also mussten wir
noch einen halben Tag in London
rumkriegen das Problem war aber dass ich
zu dem Zeitpunkt schon richtig krank war
und alles was wir gemacht haben hat sie
einfach nicht mehr toll angefühlt ich
habe nur noch an mein Bett zu Hause
gedacht und ich hasse es im Urlaub krank
zu werden ich habe mich so auf den Trip
gefreut und es war wirklich schön mal
nach ganzen Adventskalendern und blocken
ist und was weiß ich nicht alles einfach
mal ein paar Tage außer Filmen nicht
mehr zu machen so ja aber irgendwie
werde ich immer krank soweit ich mich
einmal entspanne weil ich so ein
Arbeitstier bin Spoiler Spoiler ich
nehme euch nächste Woche zu meinem
Termin mit um mir die Augenlasern zu
lassen
das heißt ich könnte danach keine Brille
mehr benötigen also die Chance ist sehr
groß ein paar mir geschrieben dass
alexibexi damit nicht so Erfolg hatte
aber ich glaube daran das Problem ist
nur ich bin jetzt krank und ich habe das
Gefühl die werden mir sagen
999 wenn sie Reizhusten oder so haben
und ich dann da liege okay wir stellen
uns das mal ganz kurz vor ich liege da
festgeschneit meine Augen fixiert und
dann mache ich so
ja ein Laser der mir irgendwas in die
Augenbraue rein und das wollen wir
natürlich nicht ne würde aber auch cool
aussehen sondern
hier jetzt ein Cliffhanger zu lassen
weil ich es einfach löschen
wir das nächste Woche ob meine Augen
operiert wurden und nächste Woche dann
auch schon die vierte Kerze dran und der
letzte Block muss Tag also leute haltet
die Ohren steif nimmt ein bisschen
Ingwer Zitrone und Vitamin D3 einfach
was gutes für Immunsystem Zink auch
nicht vergessen
um euch einfach nur ein bisschen gesund
zu halten und ich gehe mich jetzt wieder
schön ins Bett legen ich habe guence der
Adams fast fertig gute Serie und die
Schauspielerin sieht auch echt so aus
wie ich bis dann